[Music]
we are 20 months from the 2020 election
what have you heard from the media about
the candidates maybe you've heard about
how likable they are or the odds that
can win you probably haven't heard much
about their plans to balance the budget
this far out from the election why are
we even talking about polls why aren't
we talking about policy on May 26 2016 I
was working on a presidential campaign
in our headquarters office I was sitting
at my desk working on briefing memos the
staff was excited that day because the 2
o'clock hour candidate was scheduled to
give a big policy speech about workers
rights in Las Vegas so we all wanted to
watch on TV as two o'clock approached a
group of the staff peeled away from
their work and huddled around the office
TVs which were set to all the major
networks the clock ticked down 158 159
but then two o'clock came and went and
none of the network's showed that policy
speech instead all of them showed that
that's a live feed of an empty podium at
another candidates rally in North Dakota
waiting for that candidate to take the
stage that candidate was so great for
ratings that even that image drew people
to the TV it was in that moment I
thought there's a crisis with political
media in this country it's not a
Republican Democrat crisis it's an
American problem it's a problem of the
trivial in our political media where
personality scandal and polling dominate
the coverage because that's what
generates ratings and profit I thought
in that moment it's time to rethink the
model of corporate political media think
back to the 2016 election what's the
first news story that comes to mind for
you about either candidate raise your
hand if that story was about policy like
economic or a foreign policy now
and if that story was about personality
scandal or polling like emails or tweets
exactly in the 2016 election according
to Harvard Kennedy School 10% of the
coverage was about policy two-thirds was
about personality scandal and polling
the coverage of our elections has become
a reality show and as a viewer I'm part
of the problem we all are it's hard to
turn off the TV or not click on the
headline when it's sensationalized but
imagine for a moment if our political
media were free from profit pressures
free to focus only on the stories they
think the public really needs to know
and free to pursue those stories with
death and with context over the last few
weeks I've been looking at headlines
about the 2020 candidates and some of
the leading news sites here's a sampling
of some of those headlines qumola
Harris's father
criticizes her from marijuana joke
Elizabeth Warren drinks a beer on
Instagram live and gets mixed reactions
grass roots not grass fed cory booker
could be our first vegan president in
the pale of winter trump's tan remains a
state secret
what about TV if you turn on cable news
in primetime what do you see
it's probably one of two things it could
be an opinion show where you have a
partisan host delivering a cross between
an op-ed and a newscast or it could be a
new show where you probably have a split
screen with a pundit on the left and one
on the right talking past each other
about the hot new controversy of the day
at the bottom of the screen in capital
letters it probably says breaking news
it's the same breaking news headline
whether there's been a natural disaster
or if a politician made a minor speaking
death so why should you care about this
and why now because reliable information
is an anchor of a functioning democracy
and we're drifting further and further
from that anchor let's think about the
situation we're in Americans are
increasingly uninformed three-quarters
can't name the three branches of
government on top of that you've all
heard about fake news there's a blurring
of the line between truth and fiction in
our news ecosystem an MIT study this
year found that false news stories are
70% more likely to get retweeted than
real news stories there's even a merging
AI that can mass produce fake news
making it that much harder to detect and
mitigate and finally less than half of
Americans trust the mass media that's
down from 70 percent in the 1970s in
this context what will happen in the
next national security emergency
how will we all agree on what's true we
take for granted that our political
media should be run that it's ideal for
it to be run as subsidiaries of
corporate giants but that system is
largely failing at what its core mission
should be to inform and educate what if
we considered our political media to be
a public good set aside as something
different from just another product in
our economy quality information is
central for people to make informed
decisions it has benefits to our whole
society there are already news
nonprofits doing great work like
ProPublica and NPR and you know what the
most trusted institution in the entire
country is PBS we could take that model
and build a new generation of political
media nonprofits with a strictly
nonpartisan educational mission and with
stable long term capital backing from
foundations and small donors one day
maybe you'll run a company that owns
media assets maybe you'll be looking to
invest for impact when you're in that
position consider that media is part of
the lifeblood of our democracy if you
can be a force for hiring journalists
with a not not-for-profit nonpartisan
mission when newsrooms are getting
decimated and pushed towards the trivial
that's having impact and if you work at
a social media company you can help
partner with quality news organizations
rather than sidelining and replacing
them these are all long-term ideas how
can you actually help today it's not
realistic to resolve that will stop
consuming infotainment altogether but
when we do consume it we could remind
ourselves that it's entertainment not a
replacement for real news the Washington
Post columnist Margaret Sullavan has
said that in an election the media
treats policy like a helping of steamed
broccoli shove to the side of the plate
broccoli gets a bad rap but it's healthy
and it's really important for a balanced
diet maybe we can make a small pledge
here today for every few stories we
consume between now and 2020 about the
political horse race we could try to
find and read and maybe even share a
story about policy in the strongest
democracy in the world we can build a
new landscape of political media a media
can be proud of that rises above the
fray to deliver substance and context
you can help make that a reality thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]